talking about like the traditional
outcome like being a housewife so only
like roughly 20 of women get to do that
right so it's competitive like it's and
the guys that want a housewife like I
mean you have to compete for them and
typically they don't pick girls with
only fans corn stars like okay I don't
want to be a typical house well I was
only I don't I don't know what you want
I was talking about right because I said
there's moments in my life where I'm
just I'm like [__] it I'll do that
because dealing with being a woman and
dealing a black woman at that and
dealing with this Workforce like I said
I'm from La so if hell that I deal with
on a day-to-day basis and I'm sick of it
yeah but it's like at 33 like you just
can't be a traditional woman anymore I
don't think you would claim to be right
but and it's like a lot of times like we
want these traditional outcomes but it's
like do we qualify you know right right
that's very true but it's I mean it's
like damned if you do damned if you
don't at some point but with that
attitude I mean like at that point I
mean listening to everything you're
saying have you been realistic with the
men that you're going for like you're
saying like the men that you're going on
dates with like your job isn't good
enough this isn't good enough have you
ever like taken time to stop and be like
damn maybe it is me and not these men
you know what I mean like it's and I
have and I tell people that I definitely
have because I'm a Virgo I'm an
overthinker and so I analyze every
[__] thing you know what I mean and
so I do be like and that's why I just
told her when she asked are you like
really looking I'm like you know what
nobody you need to sit your ass down and
get yourself together right now well
maybe that's being real about it you
know what I mean maybe this is not the
time you know what I mean for you to be
trying to get it if you don't fully have
your [__] together if that's what guys
are going for now if you make it to 35
and you're not married you only have
like a 15 I think percent chance 20
chance right and that's almost scary
I'm sorry the dating pool in La is not
the best
are some of the worst men I've ever
experienced in my entire life they are
they are
they act like they want something
serious and they want a real
relationship and a real true loving
partner and when they get that they go
and turn around and they're like oh I
have this already and then they go and
turn around and cheat right I think
no it's because women go for a small
percentage of men
at the end of the day all I care about
is making sure that I'm loved I'd rather
have somebody who will commit to me and
tell me that they love me and actually
show me that they love me over someone
who's Chris [__] Brown I'd Rather Be
Loved than have somebody with status any
[__] day yeah I don't even know
right and I'm not I'm not talking about
you guys individually but there's no
shortage of women trying to sleep with
Chris Brown trying to sleep with Drake
trying to sleep with these entertainers
actors High staff
that women will know for a fact will not
be faithful to them they know that's
living in the city it honestly is the
further away you get from a metropolitan
area the better your odds are going to
be because it's the people in cities
there's so many people here your pool is
so deep you can just look at something
swipe left swipe right you can toss them
aside you can cheat on it's also really
easy to disguise what you're doing if
there's so many people around to be
perfectly honest because I feel like I
used to feel the same way I used to be
like oh my God I hate digging away
because I'm from Alabama like bomb
nowhere and I hated dating that but like
then I came to L.A and I was like I hate
dating in L.A and I was like well where
I had to sit down and shut the [__] up
and be like well where am I actually
looking at dating and my guy now who's
like a blue-collar job he's yeah lineman
or rig worker yeah they're great but a
lot of people don't want
to admit that those guys sometimes are
the best people and the best prospects
to date we want the flashy stuff as much
as we say we don't guess the hell we do
there's a lot of social media and say if
you don't have this if you don't have
this kind of money if you don't [__]
drive a Bugatti you're not worth my time
so a lot of these guys a lot of these
normal guys that we complain aren't
around they're around we just don't give
a [__] about them we don't give them a
chance Falls in areas if you move
outside of a major metropolitan area and
you live outside of like a medium-sized
City like 45 minutes outside of it and
you participate in life in that town
that and you work somewhere where you do
not work around the majority of the same
gender that's the biggest problem I get
a lot of people that are like nurses
teachers social workers they always talk
about how they can't find anybody they
can't find anybody because they work
with all women all women yeah I love
those types of jobs
women go into those jobs and then we
can't wait to get out of them because
you get into them and they suck well and
the other issue is women find 80 percent
of men is unattractive not okay not uh
it's you find 80 of men you meet ugly
but I'm dating ugly ones
typically tip note typically when women
work around men if you're looking for a
partner if you're looking for a spouse
you need to work around men because you
have to know them in in order to
actually know if they're attractive to
you it yes I agree with what you're
saying but the thing is women will care
less about how attractive a man is if
they are in close proximity to that man
and they like him yes that is how people
are married I know but I'm not talking
about like what's ideal I'm talking
about what is
people yeah yeah no but no now the
number one way is dating apps it's not
work anymore I think dating apps
personally are the dumbest thing created
because personally for me like I go on
personality at the end of the day like
yes the first thing you see when you
meet somebody is their looks but like
I've dated men that I haven't found
conventionally attractive and they have
been the sweetest human beings to me
ever was it because you knew them from
something other than meeting them and
like meeting them in a bar and being
attracted to them well actually so
before I also bartended on the side when
I was doing I was bartender yeah when I
was doing only fans it was in Austin he
was a DJ uh oh he worked together yes so
he was he was more well we didn't work
at the same bars but it was like the
industry Austin's a very very small
nightlife industry yeah
so the person that I dated he was not
conventionally attractive at all
overweight
just not my type that I would see at all
but his personality completely wow how
long were you with him we were together
for I mean it was
he died while we were talking but
um
it was a very amazing we were friends
before and then I just kind of switched
into something more but I think it was
it was like I knew him for a very long
time so I wouldn't say there was really
a time of us like talking but I think
that's why I think dating apps are like
the dumbest thing I agree with you I
mean if we if we meet someone on a
dating app like we only swipe right five
percent of the time so if you're meeting
with someone online like typically he's
got a lot of women because again he's
getting all of the likes I wouldn't even
be here if it wasn't for the day now
that's how I met Brian
a lot of is something I can get really
missed too a lot of us here are content
creators and if some if a guy is doing
well on a dating app it's really because
he can write sales copy and that's a
problem because it means that men who
can write sales copy and know how to
take photos that look a certain way are
the ones that get chosen over and over
and those are the wrong ones I just want
to say that when I'm on a dating app I
do read through what they put on that on
on the questions and stuff like that
because you can be the finest
[__] in the room and if I can't
carry a conversation with you and you're
not making me laugh or
Smiles the guys you're gonna match with
are the ones that know what to say yeah
they're optimized they're literally I
don't know because I've seen a lot of
really cute [__] on there
saying you don't know what this is
saying something but again but again
you're only you're only swiping right
five percent of the time
women of the product right women are the
product the men are the customers on a
date yeah women are the product it's
it's and it's I mean they're selling us
on some of them sorry to interrupt not
on all of them yeah like Bumble and
hinge yeah some of them rest of them
yeah yeah I don't think most people
really use Tinder as much anymore I
think it's at least in La it's mainly
Bumble and hinge and then the uh the
celebrity one I guess that's because
most people in La be crazy as hell and
got banned off Tinder already
La dating really is like the guys are
scared to get used for their money and
the women are scared to get used for
they [__] that's really what it is so
it's just like we we can't win Los
Angeles high school
and to be honest with the Los Angeles
dating from from being here for like
less than a year I've already noticed
that the what La is known for is they
want that instant gratification when it
comes to sex money clubs drugs
everything instant gratification they
don't want to work for for it for very
long or have it for very long if they've
already obtained it and that's what I've
noticed here I don't agree with that
because a lot of these people that are
in this area they've worked extremely
hard to get to where they're at no not
like business-wise because I've seen
people put their all into like music or
whatever their niches but I'm saying
like when it comes to dating I've
noticed that people are very quick to
like get it and then hey can you skit
into the table please or too far back
um so guys
we uh technical issues the monitors are
busted so I'm gonna have to be
controlling a lot of stuff on here so
I'm gonna read some super chats we have
bean cheeks here with the hundred thank
you George Miller is the blank that took
relative as pseudonym
oh are you talking [__] about Rolo I
don't know if I can show these man uh
or do BS vasectomy ordeal that is making
red pill content code bogus you're
welcome on educating you okay Darth
perditious thank you for the hundred
back again after calling Nala out for
her cheating King huge oh hold on let me
trigger that
I can't see any of these by the way guys
so I'm just a huge fan of Gwen and Zoe
Zoe based as [__]
uh and impressed by your statements
Pearl have loved many of your shows just
hate some of the feminists oh okay thank
you Darth perditious we have here
Odin thank you for the 100 it is said
people have looks or personality girls
that rated themselves a 10 does this
mean you have no personality also why
does height add to a guy's
attractiveness score curious as a 6-5
guy okay why does height
well first off does uh height matter I
don't think so
it hasn't historically like with the
people the people dated
they've been all over the board like
height wise but I think sometimes it's
nice to feel small
nice to feel small okay I think
personally hi does matter for me because
looking for somebody to be the father of
my kids and my dad is five five and
I need somebody to balance out my genes
you know
okay uh hold on flan life thanks for the
gifted by the way guys it's like I said
major technical issues so all the super
chats is gonna be scuffed TTS is gonna
be TTS is working but it's scuffed ish
um okay so height
um
do you have a height minimum
well I'm only five feet tall so I say
you got to be at least taller than my
dad
how tall is your five five okay you have
to balance out his genes if we have sons
they gotta they have to be at least
taller than five five good looking you
know yeah I don't want to do that to
them
all right okay we have uh wait hold on
why does height add to a guy's
attractiveness score
does anyone I think honestly for me I'm
five nine when a guy is Too Tall like
cause All My Exes have been around like
five nine five eight I had two x's one
was six two one was six one
any guy over six one for me to start
they just start to look funny so I can't
I think that's like biological because
we like we're looking for protectors
yeah
okay all right Odin thank you man
appreciate it we have uh doc van nablis
thank you the golden ratio is the
objective standard of beauty and
preserved not only across cultures but
also nature one one to 1.6 look up the
marquart mask and see how your face
conforms to the golden ratio while we
could pull it up if our monitors weren't
scuffed um doc thank you man appreciate
it uh depper Dave thank you man uh Pearl
gave a poor example of red pilled from
The Matrix it means you see the world
now and see oh [__] I didn't pull it up
sorry guys you see how modern Western
wait what
it means you see the world now and see
how modern Western women operate
delusional on what men really want yes
body count does matter
okay that's what you said you can't like
would you say the definition of red pill
you just can't win like I feel like
that's what you said all right we have
uh Bob dunnaway here thank you man uh
long time voyeur first time donator hey
thank you man welcome for joining I
apologize that your first uh chat's on
an absolute scuff stream because you
brought pearly things all you women are
created thoughtfully by loving God keep
the body count down but don't live in
guilt uh live in conviction hey Bob
thank you man appreciate it all right
and then we have a couple soup chats
also guys the soup chats are going to be
a little bit scuffed if I missed a
couple of the displays
um okay we have
filthy with the 100 thank you man do the
women in the adult film industry of want
to have children if so are you worried
about the effects you're at she is
pregnant
um so are you worried about the effects
your actions we'll have on them in the
future specifically for boys remember
the internet is forever and what we do
in life echoes in eternity
your response to Filthy I mean I didn't
really think about it before I got
pregnant
um but after I did
I definitely again I don't regret
anything I've done in my life because it
has gotten me to where I am today but
I wish I could have went about things
differently I wish I didn't
fully get into being able for people to
search me up on the Hub and stuff
um I'm fine with the only fans aspect of
it but yeah I mean it is not going to be
the easiest when I have if I do have a
son and they go to school and he gets
older and his friends are like hey you
know your mom's on the Hub I just looked
her up so that's also why like I'm glad
that I took a step back when I did
from being on PornHub
okay anybody else who does of won't
answer that anybody Kirsten I mean I
think it'll definitely affect children
like I said before I've had one of my
old management she was huge on PornHub
and her kids are severely bullied
because of it it definitely will I know
when I get to that point when I do
eventually want to have kids I'm going
to do my best to wipe myself from the
internet but you know what I made the
decisions that I made and I'm okay with
that I think it's just also having a
conversation with your kids and sitting
them down and letting them know
beforehand
because I would rather sit my kids down
before it gets to a certain age where
people start going on these websites and
letting them know so they're aware of it
and they can kind of get a thicker skin
before they walk into something that
they're not aware of yeah I kind of
control the narrative a little bit
exactly as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible